とって
うん
今日は外しそうです
新チャンネルを作るといって
早
1か月が作動しておりますいろいろ準備をしてきたわけなんですけども
今回その
線チャンネルの
新しいルーバーの一人を
[音楽]
紹介しようと思います
こちらです
[音楽]
はいというわけでねー
いつめんまの
大事ですこんにちはー
既視感がありますねはいという苦しいメンバーの第5クールなんですけど実はですね
もうどれくらい2年くらい
2年半2年半か2年半ぐらいですね実は僕と一緒に動画を作ってきたのは彼なんですね
顔裏方としてずっとこう
限数とかカメラマンとか色々実は裏方として手伝ってくれてたのが
回路なんですけども
まぁちょっと新チャンネルを機になとこあったじゃないか移る時がない地区も2とやっ
たけど
ございいく処理とかなーいってもそうねっ
ねぇ最悪ですちんちん何回も何回もなくしてさらにそして人のせいにする
[ __ ]中 jump to 払ったあれがめんどくさいので出ることになりました
そんなにいうあの自己紹介した後みなさんこんにちは
えっ
立ち目真の第1位ですペット1年齢は
う
始めくると年齢は一君と同じ
1993年生まれの25歳です
同い年の子ないらっしゃいましてまたあれだよ産褥
もそう同じ2月のみが頭で年齢がとても使いのでございますはい
他言うことありませんちょっと情報が少ないんですけども本当に何かいるまでここで
行ってきたのは彼の村の支えがあったから去っていることでもデカいんでどんな性格な
のってものか変なスルーですね
よくサイコパス太鼓いますね変わってる方なんで
今後ともよろしくお願い致しまーします
ねここでトップ線チャンネルの一したとするのって話があるんですけど
あの正式な一日が始まりました
[音楽]
信者寝るわ
5月の
2頭でございます
[拍手]
5押さえつけましたねこれはそうですねゴールデンウィークの前日の夜完璧な
タイミングでございますまだちょっと準備期間いろいろ
ぱぱらっとしてるわけなんですけどもあったの市民という形ございます
ちんちん
me
あっはぁ